hello everyone and welcome back to round
five coverage here in Zagreb and we have
a very special guest with us right now
the one and only garry kasparov in the
building
Gary we know you're doing a lot of work
with the young stars program and you've
been treating us by coming here today
and here on different days as well
today's games they have a bit of
strangeness to them it feels like missed
opportunities what do you what are your
thoughts on this yeah plenty of missed
opportunities I was especially amazed by
Aronian missing one opportunity to win
after another I mean it always happens
in big tournaments but probably to the
end of the tournament and it seems that
just it's just to have so many mistakes
in the beginning but what tells us that
maybe these best players in the world
they are just to play too much so this
is the scene with too much pressure
preparation and go from one to me to
another I don't see any other
explanation because this is the some of
the games they're just you know is that
you couldn't explain it from a pure
chess point of view so this is a
mistakes they made and and definitely
they they don't show what they are
capable of but the media of a rolling
game is quite you know it's quite
special even even by these standards but
yesterday we saw another crazy game
madness played money they are off but
they were even call inaccuracies but the
game was absolutely crazy and it was
very difficulty what was it it was a
computer to understand what's what's
going on I mean the game today was with
Mattel Aronian it was just you don't
need a computer to understand that White
was dead lost and I mean I Ronan had to
work hard not to win the game indeed you
take us back to your time how how many
games a year did you play and think was
ideal to play yeah look it's it is
there's no ideal Widow recipe so this is
all plans and different and i i played
fewer games than than a lot of players
but that's probably influence of both
manic and also i needed more time for
preparation just to feel how hunger for
again
very hungry and just do to to sort of to
push my adrenaline back I think that I
was just at the range of maybe you know
60 70 games a year so now they easily
double it and I was all there appeared
on blitz and especially this year I mean
this is totally crazy schedule because
all of a sudden feeder came up came back
with this full Grand Prix's so this is
it stick the it's you look at the
calendar of this year is just you know
you can find Pro Verde without big chess
event being played somewhere so great
for the fans but certainly I'm not sure
it's great for the fans because fans are
not just you know Delta here just watch
Magnus and Iranian and MVL and Caruana
playing they want them to play good
chess and it's yeah there's probably
there are limits for mistakes they're
making and it's just it's I mean I can
upload the fighting spirit and we talked
about Magnus trying really hard just you
know just to push his luck but still you
know we want them to be fresh we want
them to play brilliant games that's
that's that's why we're watching this
torment we see it in sports all the time
we see players get rest and in
basketball Kawhi Leonard of the Raptors
they would arrest him so that he'll be
effective for the finalists but we see
it in tennis as well they don't or
doesn't play everything there's only one
Wednesday here so it's that's and again
it's not just about one torment you know
just you know you go from torment to
torment it's like you know chepito is a
circus so and I I think that's you know
this they the calendar should be should
be balanced and because they're getting
exhausted all right well this game
you're stunned at this position now now
it's now it's fine I mean it's okay
that's the game is still not all world
but it's just a running blunder anything
could could because I mean I was at one
point you know he said she just had you
know he eventually he sacrificed the
piece you know completely awesome and
this is four pieces for passports
yeah and it's why have no women no no
real come to play and and then he went
for brilliancy so with the cease remove
yeah and an after Bishop with one well
it's Bishop e2 and just
it was yeah it's they're still few more
moves to be made the Queen takes of six
bishop takes the one queen tha King the
seven I'm sorry the pole is unstoppable
so is the yeah and any wonder you know
just it sits in this position I mean why
don't you don't play Luke these three
you cannot take out of things because
whom do you want check so and then just
eight porn is marching so I don't know
I'm I'm still confused not very happy
but even at the end you know this is it
just here you know this this this
position so I mean okay this is this you
already did your task more much more
difficult but protect the poem I mean
this White has nothing to do I mean they
did understand he's afraid maybe there
could be some threads but but like
always can cut you know this d2 so they
the DD file there's nothing's happening
here because b2 poem is there and it's
just waiting he's just standing there
waiting for a pool to join to join the
show yes we're sad about it as
compensators trust me that we didn't see
that happen also this game with Magnus
was a little bit strange to as we saw
Sergei had a nice position in Magnus
played this move Knight BD 7 and f4 of
course typical pillsbury attack kind of
territory and then immediately he plays
this forcing at 5 and throws away the
better part of it is Vantage well maybe
Scout winning something but naturally
you know he could try to just to to to
move the Queen just it's the or you know
one of the were moved to the Queen so an
any one night only five so standing its
dominating the position so it's the it's
it's a it's a poison gambit to decline
so this some sort of total attack and
I'm a white in Joyce you know very
comfortable edge and I I want many games
was the night only five so that's why
for me it would be natural I will do in
the consider I five because in exchange
so why do you change this Bishop on this
reproducibly 26 I mean just look at is
two pieces which one is better
now we're getting now a repetition
happening is what I'm hearing in my ear
in the LaVon game and the game is now
over drawn results Gary
final thoughts on before the players get
in here final thoughts on how you think
the rest of the tournaments going to go
like who's gonna have the energy is is
the palm nachi now the clear favorite to
win the tournament the way this trend is
going match is still you know to play
Magnus and that's why and as long as
this game is not played so I would
consider Magnus a favorite so but again
look so that's that's that's all we well
professional players know it counts but
you never know he can run all his own
luck by back his own fault
so that's secret but I don't know so it
seems that you know a man who still has
to get his act together and I think he's
also tired I mean he played
phenomenally are absolutely phenomenal
chess but you know phenomenal just means
you know you spend a lot of energy and
it seems that these not just running a
little bit out of steam so you still
think he's the favorite as long as
there's a game between Magnuson and
their post so I I would I would I would
better better Magnus in his tournament
there again it's it's it's where I'm
just in equator of the tournament this
is six more rounds to go and again it
says he is one point one point behind
but we know if Magnus you know if Magnus
catches the wind so he's you know he
said was unstoppable yes indeed thank
you so much for joining us thank you
once again Gary I will throw it back to
you guys in the studio in st. Louis
thank you very much thank you Gary for
joining us and we do have a